اذا نحن في قناه العربيه وضمن سياق
التغطيه المباشره منذ اللحظات الاولى
للزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا والشمال
السوري ننقل لكم الفيديوهات التي تردنا
وايضا كل المشاهد اولا باول وحتى عمليات
الانقاذ مباشره على الهواء لان الناس
مهتمون ليعرفوا كيف هو اوضاع الذين تضرروا
بفعل الزلزال وايضا هل من ناجين ورغم مرور
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه على الزلزال المدمر
يعني مع مرور ومضيء الوقت يتقلص الامل في
البحث عن فرص نجاه الى هذا الخبر حيث قفز
عدد قتل الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وسوريا الى ما يقرب من
9,800 شخص في البلدين ولا يزال رجال
لانقاذ يسابقون الزمن في ظروف الشتاء
القاسيه لانتشال الناجين من تحت انقاذ
المباني المنهاره ففي سوريا
عدد القتلى بلغ
2751 شخصا على الاقل وفقا للمرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان اما في تركيا اعلنت السلطات
مقتله اكثر من سبعه الاف18 اشخاص واصابه
اكثر من اربعين الفا اخرين
[موسيقى]
من جانبي طالب مبعوثه سوريا في الامم
المتحده طالبت دول الاعضاء بمزيد من الدعم
للسوريين المتضررين جراء الزلزال مشيرا
الى ان العديد من الطائرات ترفض الهبوط في
المطارات السوريه بسبب العقوبات الامريكيه
والاوروبيه المفروضه على النظام
الكثير من الطائرات وطائرات الشحن ترفض
الهبوط في المطارات السوريه بسبب العقوبات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه الدول التي تريد
ارسال مساعدات انسانيه لا يمكنها استخدام
شحنه الطائرات بسبب العقوبات قله المعدات
والقدرات الحكوميه موجوده بسبب الوضع
الحالي والعقوبات ايضا لهذا السبب وجهنا
نداء لجميع الدول الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده للمساعده في هذا الوضع جميع
السوريين بحاجه الى هذه المساعده
في مرت اخوي توفت
وبنتها طالبه الجامعه
ببانياس لمشفى بانياس
جينا الساعه ثمانيه الصبح كانت الاليات
والشغيله والعمال عم تشتغل و الله يعطيه
العافيه
[موسيقى]
يارب يارب
يارب الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اذا في بيان للمعارضه السوريه الان نقاط
مهمه بدات تتوالى تتعلق بتامين ادخال
المساعدات عبر ثلاث معابر جاء بعد التواصل
مع الحكومه التركيه اذا تامين ادخال
المساعدات من معابر السلامه الراعي وايضا
باب الهوى هذا هو جديد الاخبار التي تاتي
من بيان على لسان المعارض السوريه وبعد
كانت الحديث بان معبر باب الهوى هو معطل
بفعل الزلزال والطرق المؤديه اليه حيث كان
هذا المعبر هو المقفل ولكنه كان يعتبر
الشريان الحياه شريان ادخال المساعدات الى
منطقه الشمال السوري الان وفق المعلومات
التي تريدنا الان تتحدث عن تامين ادخال
المساعدات من معابر باب السلامه والراعي
وباب الهوى طبعا كانت هذه مطالبات من قبل
المناطق التابعه لفصائل المعارضه السوريه
بفتح المعابر الاخرى وليس فقط معبر باب
الهوى بين تركيا والشمال السوري الان هذه
هي المعلومات على كل حال في سياق هذه
الساعه سنعرف المزيد والمزيد من التفاصيل
فيما يتعلق بادخال المساعده واليه ايضا
ادخال المساعدات التي تعد الان النقطه
الابرز في حاجه المواطنين سواء من الجانب
التركي او من الجانب السوري من كافه
المناطق اما من سيطره النظام السوري او
المناطق التابعه للمعارضه السوريه وحتى
المناطق التي تتولى سيطرتها تركيا هذه هي
جديد الاخبار المتعلقه حتى هذه الساعه
وسنذهب معكم ايضا في فيديوهات وصور مباشره
لكن دعم دعونا نتعرف على الوضع في
القامشلي بالتحديد الان جمعه عكاش معنا من
هناك جمعه منذ اليوم الاول وانت متواصل
على الهواء مباشره تعطينا لحظه بلحظه ما
الذي يجري الان اين تتركز عمليات الانقاذ
في القامشلي هما جديدها
نادين مرحبا بك وبس المشاهدين يعني ندعيني
ابدا من الخبر الذي انتهيت به وهو مثلا
التامين المنافذ البريه لاثقال المساعدات
نعم هناك يعني توافق بين المعارضه
والحكومه التركيه على اعاده تفعيل معبر
الراعي و باب السلامه اضافه الى معبر باب
الهوى هذه المعابر
ستكون رسميا المعابر المعتمده لادخال
المساعدات التي بدات طلائعها تتوافد الى
مطارات تركيا هناك طائرات قطريه وصلت الى
الى مطار غازي عنتاب يعتقد ان جزء كبير من
هذه المساعدات ستتجه الى اراضي السوريه
عبر معبر باب باب الهوى في معلومات عن
اليه ادخال المساعدات يعني معبر باب الهوى
معطل ومقفل بفعل الضرر الذي لحق به
الزلزال خصوصا انه يعني رئيسي يعتبر شريان
رئيسي لنقل المساعدات من البلدين
اوضح يعني المعابر المعبر الرسمي هو معبر
باب الهوى والمعتمد من مجلس الامن الدولي
لادخال المساعدات الى كامل الاراضي
السوريه لكن مع بريبه بالسلامه والراعي
وهناك معابر فرعيه اخرى كل هذه المعابر
مفتوحه ولم تغلق نهائيا بعد الزلزال لكن
لم تكن تصلها المساعدات بينما معبر باب
يعني باب الهواء الى عوده الى سؤالك هذا
المعبر غير معطل لكنه غير مفعل هناك فرق
بين معطل ومفعل لكن بعض الطرقات التي تاتي
من ولايتها التركيه تضررت بشكل كبير بفعل
الزلزال لكن المعبر نفسه لم يتضرر وكان
معطل بسبب انه المساعدات لم تصل اليه ولم
يتم اغلاقه بشكل رسمي لا من الطرف السوري
ولا حتى من الطرف التركي وبالتالي مع وجود
يعني نوع من التفاهم بين المعارضه
والحكومه يعني بالحكومه المؤق الحكومه
التركيه لاستاحه المجال معضرين اخر هما
معبر باب السلامه
والمعبر الاخر سيكون ميناء سهل الوصول ليس
فقط من من هاتاي الى
سيسهل وصول
المساعدات التي يبدو بداتنا تصل الى اراضي
التركيه باتجاه الاراضي السوريه طيب
الجمعه فقط وانت تحدثنا ننوه نشيل
للمشاهدين بين نتابع هذه الصور والمباشره
في الجزء العلوي من الشاشه على
يمين حيث مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب قبل ثلاثه
ايام وايضا اديمان هي احدى المقاطعات
والمناطق العشر التي صنفت من ضمن المناطق
المنكوبه وطبعا نتابع اسفل الشاشه عمليات
الانقاذ ما زالت جاريه في حلب في سوريا
وهذه الابنيه المهدمه وتظهر عليها اثار
الدمار وحيث ادلب على يسار اسفل الشاشه
اثار الدمار من قبل هذه الصور التي تريدنا
الجمعه عندما نتحدث عن مناطق الشمال
السوري هل فعلا المعلومات تتحدث باننا
عندما نتحدث عن مساعدات لا يريدون مساعدات
بالدرجه الاولى التي تتعلق
باقمشه
وبطانياتهم يريدون مساعدات بالدرجه الاولى
تتعلق بالجرافات والاليات هل هذا صحيح
بانه في مشكله
بالنقل الحطام والحاجه الى معدات واليات
لازاحته انتشال منهم تحت الارض
نعم نادين يعني فتتصدر قائمه الاولويات
بالنسبه لامارات شمال غرب سوريا الحصول
على
المساعدات يعني اللوجستيه الاسيويه
الاليات الثقيله رافعات الانقاض والجرافات
هذا في المقام الاول ثم ياتي المقام
الثاني وهو يعني وصول فرق انقاذ متخصصه
لان الفرق الحاليه دفاع المدني ومجموعات
المتطوعين المدنيين معهم لا يمتلكون
الخبره الكافيه للتعامل مع هذا النوع من
الكوارث رغم الجهود الكبيره الذي بدلوها
خلال ساعات الاثنين الماضيه وبالتالي
الرافعات
المعدات الثقيله الاليات الثقيله تتصدر
الاولويات لكن هناك ايضا احتياجات كبيره
احتياجات طبيه لاستمرار يعني مداوات
الجرحى الاعداد الهائله من الجرحى في
المستشفيات الطاقم الطبي ايضا يعني هناك
حاجه الى سلات الغذائيه وب
سله كامله من الاحتياجات التي في الحقيقه
لم تصل حتى الان اي شيء منها الى داخل
المناطق المنكوبه في شمال غرب البلاد طيب
الجمعه يعني بالنسبه للاولويات ما هي
المناطق والبلدات في الشمال السوري التي
يتم التركيز عليها بالدرجه الاولى اكثر من
غيرها الان
كل الاعين الان تتجه الى بلده جنديرس
الكرديه التي تعاني من كارثه حقيقيه جراءه
تدمر اكثر من 84 مبنى في هذه البلده
الصغيره الواقعه بريف مدينه عفرين فرق
الانقاذ تمكنت من الوصول الى حوالي عشرين
مبنى من هذه المباني المدمره وقاموا
بانتشال عدد يعني عدد معقول من
الناجين هذا الامطار لكن حجم الكارثه كبير
والمؤشرات تدل بان اعداد القتلى فسيكون
كبيرا في هذه المدينه علما ان هناك حاليا
يعني اكثر من 200 جثه استقبلتها مشافي
عفريت المشفى العسكري والمشفى الجيهان
الخاص من ضحايا هذه البلده مع استمرار
اعمال رفع الانقاض
وانعدام الفرصه امام العثور على ناجي جدد
ربما يصل العدد وفق التقديرات الى حوالي
500 قتيل فقط في هذه البلده الصغيره
من اكثر البلدات تضررا جنديرس في ريف
عفرين في حلب بالتحديد وايضا نتابع معكم
ما زلنا هذه الصور والمشاهدات ايضا جمعه
نريد ان نعرف بالنسبه
للمواطنين الذين
العان عاشوا في العراء وذهبوا الى الشوارع
بيوتهم مدمره هل من تفاصيل معلومات عن
انتقال المواطنين الى اماكن اكثر امنا
ربما توفير خيام لهم في بلدات اخرى مجاوره
مناطق امنه هل من المعلومات
المعلومات متوفره يعني في المدن الخمسه
الرئيسيه المتضرره سواء اللاذقيه حلب ادلب
طرطوس
وجبله يعني معظم الاسكان خاصه في المناطق
سيطره النظام التوجه الى الى مناطق امنه
في حماه الى دمشق عدد كبير من الطلاب مئات
الطلاب غادروا الامتحانات وذهبوا الى دمشق
للبحث عن الامان وكذلك العائلات بينما في
المناطق الشماليه الغربيه الالاف حتى ليله
امس كانوا في الشوارع هؤلاء لم يتمكنوا من
الوصول الى مراكز الايواء المزدحمه او الى
الحدائق العامه او حتى الى صلاه الرياضيه
المغلقه والجزء الكبير غادروا الى الارياف
لمشاركه البيوت مع يعني مع الاهل والاقارب
وحتى مع الغرباء يعني نحن نتحدث عن 7
مليون انسان متضرر في شمال غرب البلاد وفي
الساحل والداخل للسوريين يعيشون اوضاع
مزريه في المنطقتين سيطره المعارضه وحتى
النظام بالتاكيد جمعه سنكون معك في سياق
هذه التغطيه على العربيه لنعرف المزيد
والمزيد من التفاصيل الى هنا نشكرك جزيل
الشكر من القامشلي مراسل العربيه جمعه
عكاش ونذهب معكم الى سرمدا بشمال سوريا
ومعنى من هناك المتطوع في منظمه الخوض
البيضاء في راس الخليفه اهلا بك فراس معنا
ضمن سياق هذه التغطيه يعني المشاهد التي
التقطت لطائرات بدون طيار من منطقه سرمدا
بالتحديد مروعه قبل ان نتحدث عن الوضع
هناك هل لديكم اي تفاصيل اي معلومات عن ما
قيل قبل قليل وما تم على لسان المعارضه
السوريه عن ادخال المساعدات عبر ثلاث
معابر جاءت بعد التواصل مع تركيا
نعم السلام عليكم حتى اللحظه هناك ارتفاع
في حصيل الضحايا الزلزال في شمال غرب
سوريا اكثر من
1280 حاله وفاه واكثر من 2600 مصابه العدد
مرشح للارتفاع بشكل كبير بسبب وجود مئات
العوائل تحت الانقاض بما يخص وبما يخص
الوضع الانساني ما تزال فرقنا تنتشر في
عشرات المواقع وتعمل على مساعده المدنيين
واخراجها من تحت الانقاذ
جنديرسانيا حارم ارمناز سلقين عزمارين
جميع هذه المناطق مازال هناك مدنيين تحت
الانقاض وتحاول فرقنا الوصول اليهم
ومساعدتهم بما يخص المعابر الانسانيه في
الشمال السوري جميع المعابر في الشمال
مفتوحه ولكن حتى اللحظه لم يدخل اي دعم من
قبل الدول ولا المنظمات الدوليه لمساعده
فرق الدفاع المدنيه السوريه او مساعده
المدنيين وانقاذهم تحت انقاذ اعلانات
الجهات المسؤوله عن فتح هذه المعابر حتى
اللحظه لم يدخل منها اي دعم سواء اليات او
وقود او غيرها او فرق
ربما في الساعات المقبله ستتكشف المزيد من
المعلومات فيما يتعلق بالمساعدات وطبيعتها
وان كانت دخلت الى المناطق المتضرره والى
المعنيين اليوم فراس وفق عملكم في منظمه
الخوض البيضاء وتطوعكم هناك ما هي المصاعب
ما هي المعوقات التي تواجهكم في عمليات
الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه وهل تزداد الامور
تعقيدا مع مرور الوقت يعني اليوم نتحدث عن
ثلاثه ايام بعد الزلزال
نعم نتمنى باي لحظه وصول هذه المساعدات
تتواصلنا مع عده دول تواصلنا مع المنظمات
الانسانيه وهناك عود في دخول هذه
المساعدات لكن حتى اللحظه لم تدخل بما يخص
الوضع الانساني هناك وضع صعب جدا في
الشمال السوري حاله الحاله الجويه والطقس
البارد بعد اكثر بعد حوالي 72 ساعه من
الزلزال الذي ضرب الشمال السوري من لم
يكتبوا
الانقاذ التي سقطت عليه فوق بيته ربما
يقتله البرد العوائل الموجوده تحت الانقاض
وضعها كارثه وصعب اليوم فجرا استطعنا
انقاذ طفل في بلده عزمارين وما يزال هناك
اصوات العديد من المدنيين تحت ذلك البناء
التي تعمل فرقنا بكامل جهدها للوصول الى
المدني للموجودين تحت الانقاذ صراحه الوضع
صعب خارج قوه
وامكانيات الدفاع المدني والمنظمات
الموجوده هنا في الشمال السوري وبحاجه
لدعم الفرق واليات تاتي ميناء الخارج
لمساعد فرق الدفاع المدني هناك بعض
المواقع مثل
التي يوجد فيها عدد كبير من المباني
المدمره حتى اللحظه لم نستطيع الوصول الى
اغلب تلك المباني كونها بجانب بعض ومن
الصعب الوصول الى المباني الموجوده في
المركز وبالتالي الوضع صعب
وكارثه انسانيه الان موجوده في الشمال
السوري طيب
فراس يبحث عن معجزه عن بقعه ضوء عن امل في
ايجاد قلب ينبض تحت الركام واشخاص ما
زالوا احياء لكن يعني العلم والمنطق يقول
بعد مرور ثلاثه ايام تتضاءل كل هذه الامال
وان تكون ربما تتلاشى نهائيا فبالتالي هل
خفت وتيره العمل وتيره الاولويات فيما
يتعلق بالبنايات المهدمه خصوصا بعد ثلاثه
ايام
نعم بالنسبه
لعملنا نحن
نسابق الزمن في كل لحظه قد نفقد روح جديده
ولكن لدينا الامل في انقاذ المزيد من
الارواح نعمل عبر الاولويات في المباني
التي يتوقع ان يكون فيها ناجين تكون
اولوياتها عن المباني الاخرى وبالتالي
نعمل اولويات جميع كوادرنا حوالي 3000
متطوع مستنفره وتعمل على شكل زمر على مدار
24 ساعه للعمل بشكل مستمر لا يوجد هناك
انخفاض في اي وتيره للعمل لكن عدم وجود
امكانيات اكبر من ذلك من اليات من فرق
ربما يمتد العمل لوقت اكبر وبالتالي نفقد
المزيد من الارواح نحن في الدفاع المدني
السوري مستمرون بعملنا بكافه طاقاتنا لن
تخف وتيره عملنا ولن نتوقف لحظه واحده لكن
نحن كررنا ونكرر المطالبه ساعدات
من اجل الاسراع في اخراج العالقين من تحت
الانقاض لكي يكونوا على قيد الحياه
الخليفه وطبعا نذكر
بالحصيله طبعا شبه النهائيه حتى هذه
اللحظه لان العدد مرشح بالازدياد ما زال
هناك العشرات بل والمئات تحت الانقاد في
اماكن عده في الشمال السوري وايضا في
الجنوب التركي بين سوريا وتركيا وصلت
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال لاكثر من
9800 قتيل حتى هذه اللحظه
وما زلنا معكم نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
التي تاتينا من غاز عنتاب على يمين الشاشه
نتابع معكم اثار الدمار التي سويت حيث
سويت هذه المباني في الارض وهذه المباني
التي ما زالت تظهر عليها اثار الدمار
والحطام حيث سقطت المباني على رؤوس
ساكنيها منهم من نجى وكتب له الحياه مره
اخرى ومنهم ما زال تحت الانقاض حيث ما
زالت فرق الانقاذ تسعى لانتشال الجثث
وايضا انقاذ الناجين منهم حيث مازال هناك
امل من قبل منظمات
للاغاثه بان يكون هناك ناجين حتى رغم مرور
ثلاثه ايام على هذه الكارثه وعلى هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب عمق الجنوب التركي وفي
شمال سوريا بالتحديد ايضا اذا ما ذهبنا
الى كمان في تركيا ايضا حتى هذه اللحظات
عمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره هناك تمركز
لفرق الانقاذ وحتى ايضا متطوعين لمحاوله
انقاذ منهم ما زالوا عالقين بعد عنايه
ودراسه كل مكان حيث يطلب ايضا من الناس ان
يبتعدوا عن اماكن عمليات الانقاذ حتى
يتسنى
للمنقذين وايضا للدفاع المدني ان يسمعوا
اذا كان هناك اي مناشدات او اصوات لاشخاص
عالقين ما زالوا تحت الارض نتابع ايضا في
الاسفل من حلب حلب ايضا ابنيه مهدبه وهذه
هي سنوشات سيارات الاسعاف ايضا واما ادلب
نفس المشاهد وكان المشاهد اصبحت متشابهه
مجتمعه معا الصوره القاتمه واحده مشاهد
تدمي القلوب خصوصا وان العالم اجمع
اتفق بعد ان بعد ان كان السياسيون لم
يتفقوا في السياسه ولكن اليوم كل
المطالبات والمناشدات بان الانسانيه فوق
السياسه وفوق المناكفات الانسانيه التي
تجري بالتالي المطالبات لفتح كل المعابر
وايضا بايصال المساعدات باسرع وقت ممكن
لكل المناطق في سوريا على اختلاف
انتماءاتها سواء للنظام السوري وايضا
للمعارضه السوريه وغير التابعه لتركيا
[موسيقى]
بينما تسبب زلزال تركيا وسوريا في فقدان
ووفاه الكثير من الاطفال كتب لاخرين عمر
جديد بعدما نجح رجال الانقاذ في انتشالها
الى الان لا توجد احصائيات دقيقه حول عدد
الوفيات في صفوف الاطفال لكن توقعات تشير
الى انها مرتفعه بحسب يونيسف
بريطانيا تلحق بركب الدول التي تعلن عن
مساعدات اضافيه للخوذ البيضاء السوريه
بقيمه 800 الف جنيه استرليني هذا جديد
الاخبار التي تاتي من المملكه المتحده حيث
اعلنت عن مساعدات اضافيه بقيمه 800 الف
جنيه استرليني حقيقه في التقرير الذي
عرضناه الان هذه الزاويه مهمه جدا فيما
يتعلق بالاثر النفسي للاطفال نحن نتحدث عن
الجرح الجرح الذي يندمل بطبيعه الحال
ويزول ويشفى ولكن يبقى الاثر النفسي وما
يتلو ذلك منا تبعات نفسيه خصوصا على
الاطفال لنناقش هذه الزاويه معنا من عمان
الدكتوره رشا التميمي اختصاصيه نفسيه
دكتوره رشا اهلا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه
هل تدوم الازمه النفسيه يبقى ذكراها عالقا
في ذهن الطفل للابد حتى ر عندما يكبر ام
يمكن ان تمحى من الذاكره الى تم تطوير
الفرد والاهتمام به على الصعيد اصحيه
اسعد الله مسائك ومسائكم جميعا المشاهدين
الان ما يحدث لدى الاطفال السوريين
والاتراك يعني نعزي الجميع بالضحايا
ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل
من هم مرضى الان تحت اسره الشفاء في اسره
الشفاء الان الاثر النفسي نعم عند كميه
كبيره من عدد كبير من الاطفال يبقى معهم
لباقي حياتهم خصوصا اذا لم يتعرضوا
للتاهيل والتدريب
والعنايه النفسيه اللازمه التي ذكرتيها
لكن بشكل عام حسب نظافه الصحه العالميه اي
شعب
يتعرض لكارثه طبيعيه سواء زلازل فيضانات
حرائق 20% من من هذا الشعب هو معرض
لاضطرابات نفسيه واختلالات في الصحه
النفسيه لذلك طبعا احنا دائما بنعرف
الشريحه الاضعف هي الاطفال واليافعين
والمراهقين
التركيز وجل الاهتمام كما هو على الكبار
يفترض ان يكون ايضا على الفئه العمريه
الصغيره
كان كان هذا واضحا من خلال الفيديوهات
التي تريدنا ونعرضها على شاشه العربيه
في صدمه على وجوه الاطفال الى جانب الخوف
هذه الصدمه يعني تحمل تبعات لما يحصل في
السنوات المقبله اليوم كيف يمكن تنميه
الصحه النفسيه لمن يعانون من تروما
الزلازل حتى ما يتبعه ايضا من تداعيات
الان نحن في علم النفس لدينا ما يسمى
باضطراب الضغط الحاد اللي هو الاكيوت
ستريس واضطراب او كرب ما بعد الصدمه
الاضطراب الضغط الحاد ممكن انه يستمر من
يوم الى ثلاثه اسابيع اذا تعدى الاربع
اسابيع فما فوق هنا ندخل في اضطراب ما
يسمى اضطراب الضغط ما بعد الصدمه اللي هو
بيكون احد الاضطرابات النفسيه الشهيره
والمعروفه طبعا
ويعاني فيها الطفل او حتى البالغ من من
يعني اعراب مرحله دكتوره رشا ومن ثم ممكن
يتعافى ويشفى اذا اذا تعرض لخدمات نفسيه
مؤهله واحترافيه يمكن اني يتجاوز هذه
الفتره ولكن كما ذكرت في بدايه التقرير
انه هو سيتجاوز نفسيا ولكن لا نستطيع ان
نمحي الصور اللي في مخيلته ولكن نحن
نستطيع من خلال العلاج النفسي والتاهيل
النفسي ان نحيد اثر هذه الصوره او الخبره
النفسيه المزعجه الصادمه التي اشعرته
بالعزل والخوف والارتباك حين راى نفسه
معرض للموت وحين راى من حوله توفي سواء
الاب سواء ام سواء اقارب اخوان هذا كان
يكون مشهد مزعج وصادم وخصوصا انه غير
متنبا به
واشعر الفرد بالعجز واشعر بالوحده فهون
اذا لم يتعرض لخدمه نفسيه احترافيه وفوريه
ايضا ممكن ان يستمر ويتشعب بان تعقد
المساله بان يصبح اضطراب ضغط ما بعد
الصدمه يرتبط به اضطرابات اخرى زي القلق
وزي الاكتئاب اعتراف ما بعد الصدمه فيه
الاحلام المزعجه
الذكرى السيئه صور تاتي للفرد لتجنب كل ما
له علاقه باي زلازل وباي شيء له ارتدادات
او له هزات خفيفه يصبح يربط بين اي شيء له
علاقه بالزلازل ويصبح شخص خائف وشخص متوتر
فيما فيما يلحق ذلك من مراحل العمريه
لاحقه ممكن ان يؤثر في علاقاته كاب لاحقا
او كام كاخت كزوجه كله يتاثر والثقه
بالنفس ايضا تتاثر طيب الدكتوره رشا بعلم
النفس هناك ما يقال عن الاثر العكسي
والفعل العكسي هل يجب عمل فعل معاكس
بالاساس للاطفال يعني يقوم الافراد
والبالغون بالتهويل من فكره الزلازل
بالاساس رؤيه الطفل بخطرها حتى يكون
مستعدا ولا يصاب بهذه الصدمه النفسيه بعد
حصول الكارثه
هل ذكرتي تهويل ام تهوين يعني مثلا ان
يكون هناك عمليات تثقيف وتوعيه للاطفال
وتخويفهم من فكره الزلزال حتى يكونوا
مستعدين نفسيا وذهنيا مثلا الان الكوارث
الطبيعيه مثلها مثل اي شيء ممكن انه يحدث
مع الانسان يعرض الانسان لا سمح الله في
اي وقت للحرائق للزلازل للفيضانات لوقوعها
سقوطه من اشياء معين تعرضوا لحادث هلا
كوني انا كولي امر اني انا اعرض الطفل
للتثقيف يختلف عن التهويل التهويل هو انه
يصبح عند الفرد فكره انه هذا الحدث هو حدث
كارثي ولا يستطيع ان افعل شيء معه وهون
هون احنا بنمنع ونسد نضع حاجز امام الطفل
او المراهق او حتى اهله لاحقا انه هذا
يمكن ان يعالج او يمكن ان يتم اتخاذ
اجراءات نفسيه مناسبه حتى يتجاوز المرحله
اما التثقيف التثقيف نستطيع انه نعطيه
احنا معلومات مناسبه كما ذكرت هذا الشيء
يعني محبذ انه يعني يتعرض له للطفل بالعكس
انه نعطيه مثلا الاسعافات الاوليه اذا حدث
ذلك كيف يمكن ان تتصرف اين اين يمكنك ان
تقف في الزوايا اذا كان في هناك ملاجئ
بالعكس هذا الامر تثقيفي وتوعيه جيده تخفف
من اثر
الصدمه اللي انا ذكرت لك اياها وهو المكون
الاساسي فيها للصدمات انه غير متنبا فيه
بالعكس انا اذا كنت مهيئ الطفل لهذا الشيء
ونوعا ما انا اعلم انه هو فعلا امر جدا
كبير وجلل ولكن قدر الامكان نحن كطبيعه
بشر اذا كنا مهيئين للشيء
الصدمه تكون اقل والاثر النفسي الشديد
يكون اقل الكارثيه تكون اقل اهم ودكتور
رشه يعني 23 مليون شخص تغيرت حياتهم بفعل
دقيقه الى دقيقتين كل شيء تغير خلال
الثلاثه ايام اليوم عندما نتحدث عن اطفال
اصيبوا بصدمه نفسيه روما بفعل ما حصلوا
هذه المشاهد الخوف والصدمه وغير ذلك كيف
لنا ان نتخيل جيل المستقبل هذا الجيل جيل
الاطفال الذين يكبرون وهم يحملون هذا
الاذى النفسي والصدمه النفسيه
نتخيلهم جيل ممكن انه نزرع فيه نوع من
على قدر الالم الذي الذي تعرضوا له يمكن
ان نزرع فيه نوع من التكيف ونوع من الصلاه
بالنفسيه يعني كما نعلم انه الضربه التي
لا تميتك يمكن ان تقويك اذا ارتبطت فيه
خدمه نفسيه جيده يعني انا ممكن انه انا
احول نظرتي من نظره سلبيه بحته الى نظره
فيها شيء من الايجابيه رغم لا ننكر هذا
الالم الذي مروا فيه سيمر فيه لاحقا ايضا
اذا لم يتعافوا نفسيا بشكل جيد ان نعمل
على موضوع الصلابه النفسيه اللي هو
الرزلينز التحمل النفسي بان يصبح
ما اقل من ذلك يمكن انه انه لا يثير
الخوف والرعب بهذه الدرجه ويمكن ان يكونوا
مهيئين بدرجه اكبر من غيرهم ولكن هذا طبعا
مشروط بوجود خدمه نفسيه تهيئهم على سبيل
المثال احد العلاجات المهمه لتسهيل
التعافي من الصدمه لهذه الفئه اللي هو
الكنترول فوكس اللي هو العلاج المتمركز
على انه
السلوك نفسه انا اسيطر عليه اعلمه انه انا
كيف اشرط ما بين خبره السيئه الخبره
الصادمه التي تعرض لها في الزلزال مع خبره
اخرى
تشعر بالامان الى حين ان يعني يزول منه
نوعا ما الاثر المخيف لهذه الزلازل لاحقا
طبعا بدها عدد من الجلسات
يعني الاهتمام النفسي المناسب
افراد دكتوره رشا اليوم في يوم عالمي
للطفل هناك اهتمام عالمي بالاطفال وقضايا
الاطفال وما يتعرضون له سواء من حروب
وايضا من كوارث طبيعيه اليوم ما المطلوب
من الحكومات وهل يمكن تخصيص ادارات تعنى
بمساله الصحه النفسيه التي تبدا مع الطفل
ثم الفرد عندما يكبر نعم في الوضع العادي
اشكرك على السؤال في الوضع العادي يفترض
وينبغي ان يكون لكل حكومه
تخصص خدمات نفسيه ولجميع الفئات ولجميع
الاحتياجات ولجميع صراحه الفئات الشرائح
الطبقات الماديه يعني خدمات نفسيه تتوفر
للجميع فما بالك اذا كان هناك حدثت كوارث
طبيعيه كهذه حتى زي كورونا فيما سبق من
هذه الزلازل ان يكون هناك خدمات نفسيه
مؤهله وما يسمى
بدائره الازمات والكوارث ان تكون دائما
على هوبه الاستعداد بان تقدم هذه الخدمات
ولكن اريد ان اشير يعني واؤكد انه لا
نستطيع ان نصعد لتوفير خدمات نفسيه
الامانه النفسيه تقدير الذات الشعور
بالسلام النفسي والمعافاه النفسيه قبل ان
نوفر الحاجات الاساسيه
الفسيولوجيه من ماكل وطعام وش وجود ماوى
ووجود ملجا يحتمون به ويسكنون فيفا
الدرجه الاولى وجود هذه الاحتياجات
تلبيتها من ثم الصعود لتلبيه الحاجات
النفسيه ونعود الى دائره الامان التي
يريدها اي طفل في هذا العالم شكرا جزيلا
لك يا دكتوره رشا تميمه اختصاصيه نفسيه
شكرا
شفت واحد اجره
نامت تنزل ما تخاف قول يا رب
[موسيقى]
مستوى
ازمه داخل ازمه وزلزال داخل زلزال هكذا
يوصف الوضع في حلب السوريه التي يزورها
الدمار من الارض هذه المره بعد ان زارها
من السماء
حلب تبدو من اكثر المناطق تضررا بالزلزال
فهي لم تتعافى بعد من اثار الحرب المدمره
التي شهدتها عام 2011 وفي السنوات التي
تلتها
[موسيقى]
المدينه كانت اصلا ملادا لمئات الالاف ممن
فقدوا منازلهم وقد زاد عدد هؤلاء اليوم
اضعافا
خسرت اولادي حتى البيت البيت
واذا كانت سلطات النظام تمسك بزمام الامور
في المدينه فان الوضع في ريفها اكثر
تعقيدا مع وجود مناطق نفوذ لقوات كرديه
واخرى معارضه وفي تلك الانحاء الصراع لم
ينتهي قط
اما الماساه الكبرى فهي لا شك على مستوى
المساعدات الانسانيه التي تحتاجها حلب ومع
العزله النسبيه المستمره للنظام السوري مع
العالم لا يمكن للمساعدات ان تصل الا من
خلال معبر صغير على الحدود التركيه
وفيما تبدو عمليات الاغاثه في تركيا
متقدمه رغم فداحه الظروف فان الوضع في
سوريا اكثر ماساويه وتزيد من ماسويته
المباني المتصدعه اصلا بفعل النزاع
اما المنشات الطبيه فلا تنجو بدورها
مستشفيات تداعت وانهارت بسبب الزلزال
واخرى تكافح الاستقبال الجرح القادمين
بالالاف سرير واحد لكل مصابين اثنين او
ثلاثه واخرون يتناوبون على جهاز التنفس
واحد وهكذا يكتب لحلب فصل جديد من فصول
الماساه ولعله يكتب لها ايضا فصل جديد من
فصول الامن
[موسيقى]
على صعيد الجهود الاغاثيه تواصل الحمله
السعوديه استقبال التبرعات لاغاثه
المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا حيث
تجاوز اجماليه التبرعات احد عشر مليون
ريال خلال خمسه عشره ساعه من اطلاق الحمله
وكان العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجهها مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه بتسيير جسر جويا الى تركيا
وسوريا وتقديم المساعدات صحيه وايوائيه
وغذائيه لتخفيف اثار الزلازل
نذهب الى مقر المركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
في الرياض ومعنى من هناك مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن اهلا بك
معنا في هذه التغطيه المباشره على العربيه
نريد ان نعرف اولا قبل الحديث عن انطلاق
الجسر الجوي الذي من المفترض ان ينطلق بعد
ساعه من الان طبيعه الحمله السعوديه حيث
انتم الان عبد المحسن
متضررين زلزال تركيا
نعم من خلال هذه الاموال التي يتم جمعها
عبر المنصه يتم تحويلها مباشره الى منتجات
اغاثيه وطبيبيه وكافه المنتجات المتوفره
التي يتم تتم ارسالها عبر هذا الجسر الجوي
الذي سينطلق بعد ربما اقل من ساعات من
الان فبالتالي الاستجابه سريعه جدا وعمليه
جمع الاموال المستمره بالاضافه الى الدعم
الحكومي
والمساعدات الحكوميه التي ستسير بعد ساعات
فبالتالي هذا يساعد على الديمومه هذا
الموضوع واستمراره لايام متعدده وربما حتى
لاسابيع خصوصا وان مسؤوليه مركز الملك
سلمان قالوا بانهم سيتواجدون حتى ما بعد
عمليات الانتهاء من
المساعده في الجانب الاستجابه السريع في
عمليه رفع الانقاذ والمساعده السريعه الى
عمليه اعاده التاهيل وبناء الاعمار يعني
من خلال تواجدكم وايضا ما تلحظونهما حجم
الاستجابه للحمله السعوديه لاستقبال
التبرعات العاجله واللاز
نعم نادين بالفعل حجم الاستجابه سريع جدا
كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل بانه حتى الان لم
يتم الاعلان بشكل رسمي وهذا المؤتمر متوقع
ان يكون هو الاعلان الاكبر لهذه الحمله
الا ان الناس لم تنتظر حتى هذا الوقت
وبدات بالتبرع بشكل مباشر وحتى 90 الف شخص
دخلوا الى هذا الموقع وتبرعوا بشكل مباشر
وساهموا في جمع هذه الملايين التي وصلت
الى ما يقال ب 12 مليون حتى هذه اللحظه
وهو الرقم يتحدث بشكل كبير فبالتالي يتوقع
ان يكون هناك تفاعل كبير جدا خصوصا وان
هنا في السعوديه هم متعودون على هذه
الحملات الشعبيه اللي غاطت كافه المتضررين
في كافه
الحوادث الطبيعيه التي تحدث في انحاء
متفرقه من العالم وعبد المحسن هل يمكن
الحديث عن طبيعه المساعدات ما هي وعلى
ماذا تركز بالدرجه الاولى
هي تركز بشكل مباشر نادين على
المواد الايوائيه بشكل رئيسي لان هذا ما
يحتاجه الجانب التركي والسوري على حد سواء
في هذه اللحظات بالاضافه الى تواجد اطقم
طبيه
ومساعدات طبيه مباشره سيتم ارسالها عبر
هذا الجسر الجوي بالاضافه الى مواد غذائيه
ايضا ملابس شتويه لكافه المتضررين سواء
كان الموجودين في الخيانه حتى الذين لا
يزالون في مناطق الخطيره في تركيا وسوريا
في في المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال
فبالتالي هذا الجسر الجوي يحتوي على
العديد من هذه المساعدات بالاضافه الى
الخبراء الذين سيذهبون برفقه هذا الجسر
الجوي ليقيمون الاوضاع والاحتياج بشكل
مباشر
لمساعده
السلطات التركيه وحتى الجانب السوري
للاستجابه بشكل مباشر لمتطلباتهم متطلبات
الاوضاع الانسانيه هناك
من خلال هذا الجسر الجوي يعني فقط عبد
المحسن لكي نعرف تفاصيل اكثر الجسر الجوي
اين ستتركز هذه المساعدات هل
ستكون جانب السوري وهي اليه الاصاله
المساعدات
هي ستكون في كلا الجانبين بحسب مسؤولي
مركز الملك سلمان بانه لن يتم التمييز بين
احد ستصل المساعدات الى كافه
المتضررين سواء كان في الجانب التركي او
حتى في داخل
هنا نتحدث من خلال سوريا وربما صعوبه
الوصول الى المساعدات ودخولها على كل
المنظمات العالميه وليس فقط مركز الملك
سلمان تحدث المركز بانه مسؤول المركز
بانهم نسقوا مع السلطات التركيه بهذا
الخصوص لدخول المساعدات السعوديه مباشره
عبر المعابر المباشره ما بين تركيا وسوريا
الى المناطق المتضرره في سوريا بالاضافه
الى ذلك الى انهم المحوا بان هذه
المساعدات تتصل حتى الى المناطق التي
تضررت في في الجانب الذي يسيطر عليه
النظام السوري تحديدا من خلال من خلال
حملات الغاثيه او المؤسسات اللغاتيه وكافه
من يستطيع الوصول لذلك
حديث عن انه المساعدات السعوديه ستتصل الى
كافه الاماكن الى كافه المتضررين ايا كان
موقعهم وايا كان اماكن تواجدهم
من المال الاغاثه في الرياض مراسل العربيه
عبد المحسن الحربي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الزراعه التركيه ان طائره
هليكوبتر وطائره اخرى تكافحان الحريق الذي
اندلع مجددا في ميناء اسكندرون بجنوب
البلاد بعد اخماده يوم امس حيث جرى تعليق
العمليات في الميناء بعد اندلاع حريق بسبب
الزلازل والهزات الارتداديه المدمره التي
هزت المنطقه يوم الاثنين كما جرى تحويل
سفن الشحن الى موانئ اخرى
رصدت كاميرا العربيه تداعيات زلزال تركيا
في انطاكيا وسط ولايه هاتاي حيث اظهرت
انهيار المنازل وعمليات رفع الانقاذ في
محاولات مستمره لانقاذ ضحايا الهزه
الارضيه العنيفه
[موسيقى]
طبعا
ونذهب الى اضنه ومعنا من هناك زيدان زنكلو
مراسل العربيه زيدان اهلا بك معنا في سياق
هذه التغطيه التي لم تتوقف على العربيه
حيث انتم لم تهداوا منذ اللحظات الاولى
توجهتم الى كافه الاماكن وكنتم معنا اولا
باول لاعطاء المزيد من التفاصيل حتى
الساعه ما الجديد كيف هو الوضع
الصوت انقطع نادين لم اسمع السؤال
نعم نعم نعم الان وصل الصوت نعم هنا في
مدينه اضنه ما تزال جهود الانقاذ مستمره
منذ لحظه حدوث هذا الزلزال العنيف والمدمر
حتى هذه اللحظه سادع الكاميرا ترصد المشهد
وانا اتحدث اليكم طبعا في هذا المبنى
المكون من 14 طابقا طبعا قبل الزلزال سوي
هذا المبنى في الارض ما تزال جهود الانقاذ
مستمره من قبل الفرق الانقاذ تضاعفت
الاعداد التي كانت موجوده هنا من قبل فرق
الانقاذ ما بين يوم امس مساء امس عندما
وصلنا ومقارنه بما نشده الان تضاعفت
الاعداد
الاشخاص الذين يعملون في ازاله الركام
والكتل الخرسانيه عمليه دقيقه وصعبه
ومعقده حقيقه تتطلب بجهد كبير وتركيز جديد
والعمل بتانن ورويه حتى لا تحدث انهيارات
او حتى لا يعني حتى لا ينهار الركام على
اشخاص ربما يعتقد انهم ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه حسب ما علمنا قبل ان نكون معكم
مباشره على الهواء ان فرق الانقاذ استطعت
عبر اجهزه اجهزه متطوره تحديد او وصلت الى
ردات فعل بوجود اشخاص تحت هذه الانقاض حتى
الان لا يعلمون ان كانوا على قيد الحياه
امم ماتوا نتيجه الانهيارات ما اكده لنا
احد الاشخاص الذي يعمل في هذا المجال او
يرافق فرق الانقاذ يعني اشارات وفقه
تقنيات بانه قد يكون من تحت هذه البنايه
اشخاص احياء
انا اعتذر على هذه اصوات لكن الشرطه تبعد
المواطنين من هذا المكان طبعا بافقى ما
اخبرنا به هذا الشخص نعم تمكنوا من العثور
على الوصول الى اشاره على عمق ما بين
اثنين فاصله اربعه الى اثنين فاصله ثمانيه
تؤكد وجود اشخاص في هذا او على هذا العمق
لذلك كثفوا وطلبوا مساعدات اضافيه وفعلا
وصلت فرق اضافيه احد الاشخاص الذين
التقيناهم هنا من المواطنين قال لي قبل
قليل ان ابن اخيه خرج اخرج اخرج وجوه هذا
اليوم من هذا المبنى ويقول ان هناك ايضا
خمسه اشخاص
يعرفهم تماما كانوا يقيمون في الطابق
السابع هم ما زالوا تحت الانقاض ثلاثه
نساء ورجلين بحسب ما اخبرنا به هذا الشخص
لكن حتى الان السلطات ما زالت تعتقد انهم
يعني الفرصه الاخيره او ما زالت الفرص
مستمره ومازال هناك امل بالعثور
من تحت الانقاض طبعا يعني الزلزال حصل في
الساعه الرابعه فجرا الجميع كان نائما
وبالتالي
فرص النجاه او فرص امكانيه الخروج في حال
قبل انهيار المبنى ربما قد كانت ضعيفه او
نوعا ما
لذلك
الامل ما زال موجودا في العثور على
الانقاض طبعا في هذه الاعفاء العثور على
ناجين في هذه العمليه تشارك فرق فرق محليه
وايضا خبراء اجانب منها من عده دول
يشاركون في عمليه البحث والتنقيب ايضا فرق
مختصه رافقت
احضرت كلاب مدربه قامت بتمشيط المنطقه
والموقع وحددت بعض النقاط امر فريق الفريق
المشرف على العمليه نعم نادي
الكل ينتظر معجزه من بين الركام شكرا
زيدان زنكلو من اضنه كان معنا مباشره من
امام احدى البنايات التي سقطت على رؤوس
قاتنيها والحديث وفق مستشعرات بتقنيات بان
هناك اشخاصا على امل ان يكونوا على قيد
الحياه الى هنا تنتهي هذه الساعه
الاخباريه والتغطيه مستمره معكم على
العربيه الى اللقاء